The joe rogan experience.
Now there is a,
uh,
a related disease that from cats called toxic crisis,
and that's a parasitic worm infection we're finding in the United States among
the poor.
And that's a weren't.
So what happens is if you go into poor neighborhoods,
you know,
and,
uh,
you see a lot of feral cats and dogs in poor neighborhoods,
almost a hundred percent of them have this warm in their intestines and they're
seeding the environment with eggs in their feces.
And the feces are spread all over the poor neighborhoods.
Kids come into contact with him in the worm,
has the ability to migrate through the brain across the rebuild toxic crisis.
Um,
and I think it's an important cause of developmental delays.
It's one of those neglected diseases among,
in the u s and talk about in the book.
And there is no vaccine for that.
He was no vaccine for it.
And we know very little awareness about it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've never even heard of it until just now.
So this is not rare.
I mean,
in some cases,
you know,
up to 10% of certain populations,
like African,
African Americans living in poverty are infected with it.
And it's primarily pets,
or does it,
is it rodents as well?
Mostly stray dogs.
And it's not even pets.
It's mostly stray dogs and cats.
And,
and I get very,
and this is an example of a neglected tropical disease.
Here's,
here's a disease of up to 10% of African Americans living in poverty in the
United States.
And almost nobody is studying it.
Wow.
Right?
And it can affect the way your mind functions.
And it's been linked now to developmental delays.
So,
you know,
everybody wants to know why,
kids living in poverty have developmental delays and people just assume it's
because they live in deprived environments and that sort of thing.
But I think toxic crisis is an important underlying reason for it.
Um,
and this is an example of a neglected disease.
You know,
we,
I mean,
everybody's heard of Ebola,
right?
And everyone's worried about Ebola and,
and the truth is Ebola is never going to come to the United States.
Why is it ever going to be,
cause it's too difficult to transmit.
Um,
unless you have a complete collapse in the health system.
We're never going to have Ebola epidemics in the United States,
but here's a disease of 10% of African Americans living in poverty and no one's
heard of it and there's no incentive to study it.
So that's why I'm trying to raise awareness about these poverty related
diseases.
And that's correct.
I mean,
I don't understand why people don't talk about that one.
Yeah,
that one seems insane,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a no brainer.
Right?
And so,
but you know,
it's very hard to get people to care.
A bunch of things happened all at once.
And this was in 2013.
Um,
I didn't want to leave because I had little kids,
so I didn't want to,
I was,
I was going to stay there and,
and just wither wither away.
Um,
I,
I almost capitulated,
you know,
to darkness.
Uh,
but I got up before I went to sleep one night,
my kid is sleeping with me and I'm hammered and it's like eight at night,
you know.
And,
uh,
and,
um,
I had an epiphany.
I said,
you know what?
I can't,
I can't do this and I will not.
I remember saying this to myself,
I will not,
I will not be defeated.
And I put my running shoes by the side of my bed and some shorts set my alarm
clock,
got up early next morning and went for a run I la Forrest Gump,
uh,
and a pound the pavement for about 10 or 12 miles.
And I'm not a runner,
you know,
I like to run.
I like to spirit.
And when I came back from the run,
worked out in my driveway for about an hour and,
uh,
my local cops came all happened at the same time.
And,
uh,
they came and said,
hey bro,
get the fuck out kids to be all right.
You need to do this and that.
And,
um,
then I started,
uh,
kind of figuring out
re,
uh,
reevaluating my path in life.
Oh,
back up a step.
I got also got laid off from this corporation.
And you know,
with a guy in the military,
you don't,
you don't ever think about job security.
And whenever we're tired,
I'm working for a corporation that was mostly made up of a retired military
guys.
So you get laid off and you're like,
what the fuck am I going to do now?
What does that even mean?
Getting laid off?
I don't,
what am I going to do?
Um,
so all that shit happened at the same time.
It was like a,
it was like this massive spiral of bad events and a man I was able to,
um,
I was able to rekindle my own,
my own,
my own fire because I recognize,
all right bro,
you still got an amber,
you still got this.
All you need to do is just nurture that amber,
turn it into a flame,
turn that into a flame and then just start adding would add would add wood until
it becomes just a perpetual
blaze.
And which led me to this thing that I tell people now,
you know,
is that,
uh,
you got to keep the blaze alive.
Um,
I've got that on t shirts even because I,
I like,
I like to kick people in the ass who are willing to sustain their own fire once
they get that ass kicking.
If they can't,
if they can't keep their fire going and it's not worth,
it's not worth it for me,
you know,
to,
to keep kicking them in the ass.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
so ever since that point in time and you know,
getting laid off the depression,
the booze,
and,
uh,
I was able to read,
discover me and rebrand and,
and,
um,
pretty much start from scratch.
I mean,
I had to start life all over again when I was 48 years old.
Wow.
Have the whole thing from scratch.
I think that the idea that this was just some,
um,
is just not,
it doesn't respect the significance of what they were trying to do and how
effective that they were with these other things where even if they're just
trying it out just a little bit,
just working to see what works.
They're always experimenting.
They're always trying to find ways to create that tension.
Um,
and that's the thing that I think is so interesting about this,
right?
This evolving,
this idea of an information war where these tactics evolve.
Um,
and you are really at a disadvantage when it comes to actually detecting them.
One of the things about hunter that's really intoxicating is that his sort of
self destructive path becomes romantic when you read it and you get involved in
his work and you kind of mimic it,
you know,
it's,
uh,
that's the greatest fallacy I think.
I think what he was trying to say with self destruction was that this wasn't an
incredible threat to our American democracy.
Not,
I don't mean that.
I mean,
I mean his,
no romanticism tilling his,
well,
I mean,
there,
the romantic aspect of it was,
it,
his work was fantastic.
I mean,
window was till it wasn't,
it was fantastic till it wasn't,
wasn't he understood he was within the physio.
It was,
but he lived in with,
he spent much more time within the consequences of that bingeing than he did
within the success of the bingeing.
Right.
And that I think he knew that it is letters.
It's really beautiful and heartbreaking and in his riding too,
I mean I think that's what's been missed about him is there's no romanticism and
self destruction right towards the end.
He definitely lost his productivity and Yon Warner talked about that and the
Alex give me documentary.
He just,
sticky fingers was a great,
the document I,
the new book on the New Book on Yon Winner has great moments of Thompson,
the 70s just being kind of lost.
Yeah,
I think,
I think we got to remember that we have an incredible times in American history.
We have times that are going to burn brightly and it's up to each rider to
decide how they'd like to burn next to it.
And if you're going to burn brightly,
they may not have other times.
And that's I think an American thing where you can wager that bright flame,
which means you may have nothing left afterwards,
but Thompson knew that he may have to live in that kind of afterlife.
I want one.
Thompson writes about it so beautifully.
Yeah.
Stories.
I tell myself there's some,
some footage of him when he was writing for,
I forget what newspaper someone was it somewhere in the Pacific northwest.
What,
what was your writing for?
Who is the author of playing off the rail?
D Google,
uh,
playing off the rail.
There's a guy who was a journalist,
but year,
do you think it was David Mccumber?
Yes.
David McCumber,
Dave and Macomber employed hunter for awhile when David was,
um,
I forget what publication he was working for,
but there's some footage of them community communicating together and,
you know,
just trying to get hunter in San Francisco was in San Francisco and hunter's
just out of his fucking mind.
I mean,
it was younger.
You mean he wasn't even that old,
but he was just,
he just couldn't communicate.
He couldn't talk.
And,
uh,
you know,
he made a beat.
He and makes the beast have you escape the pain of articulation.
You escape the pain of saying this is what's wrong in American society.
For him to say the way he did,
one of his great essay is this from 1964 is by going to Hemingway's.
Um,
Ketchum Idaho on grave and Hemingway's house and it,
it's gorgeous because it talks about Hemingway was a good writer,
one of the best writers when he was writing about an up period,
he understood the 1940 [inaudible] 1930s when there was a firmness to the
reality that he could articulate.
One of the writers goals is to give a pattern to chaos,
is to give an articulation to cast.
But what happens in the 1960s when the chaos is multiplying repeatedly,
somebody like Hemingway becomes a literal relic.
Like his narrative no longer fits into the present that he's in.
And Thompson saw Hemingway's decline and he wrote about Hemingway's.
Um,
suicide by me,
by his narrative doesn't fit Hemingway's idea of what America was and what a man
should be fit perfectly with what I think the twenties to the forties when we
experienced.
But I think in the early 1960s with our social upheaval of civil rights,
of,
um,
you know,
political upheaval,
Hemingway,
it was confusing to him.
It didn't,
it didn't fit anymore.
Like his way of operating no longer articulated the presence.
And so Hemingway's last act was to take away his ability to say anything at all.
That was his only.
The last thing I ever said was to say,
I'm not going to say anything anymore,
was the suicide that Hemingway committed and Thompson wrote about that
cordially.
The only problem with those gals is that there is a reality to certain levels of
musculature that most likely they're only achieved by injecting male hormones so
that the clits kind of get big or whatever.
But can you tell?
No,
but I feel like we should bro.
There's a dick on inside and nut.
Get that one down there.
Yeah.
That's what happens.
It's not real.
It is real.
It is real way.
No,
no,
it is no way.
How about that one in the lower right hand,
upper right hand corner,
the dark one.
Jamie.
Below that.
That one.
Pow.
How'd you like me now?
That's a Dick Balls.
Yeah.
No,
no.
That's pussy lips,
bro.
That's not,
that's not how,
that's Pussy Lips,
Doug.
Okay.
See Lips.
Now that one down there.
What about the giant one below that?
Jamie did the one in the middle.
What's happening there,
Bro,
that just looks like a witch finger
is gnarly,
man.
That's Photoshop has to be from my shit,
dude.
Dude.
This is might be hermaphrodite free porn.
Mm.
Yeah.
Oh,
dude.
Well,
when girls take a lot of testosterone,
they do develop enlarge clits.
There was a,
a,
a show on HBO back in the day,
I think it was called private dicks,
but it was like that girl's Jack.
You're into into that though?
No,
that's a little much.
Yeah.
Dillashaw yeah,
that's Lerer pretty looking now.
She wasn't flux and told to eat a couple of sandwiches.
All right.
Well anyway,
let's get out of there.
That's,
that's enough.
We're going to start vomiting mood.
I mean,
it gets to a certain size where that's like,
it's wrapped around her leg and tied in a bow.
You're like,
hey,
or you gotta like kind of like push it to the side to insert.
You gotta hold it like a handle all your bad choice.
Fuck you.
It's like the tones,
the reins on a horse.
Like you're hanging onto it.
Where are you bang on it.
Oh,
okay.